الان في احد المنازل التي تم قصفها الليله
هنا في جباليا البلد شمال قطاع غزه حيث
اصفر هذا القصف عن وجود عدد من الشهداء
ومن الاصابات وما زال الاهالي يبحثون عن
عدد من المفقودين تحت ركام هذا المنزل هذا
المنزل يعود لعائله هنا في جباليا
البلد المنزل كان ماهول بالسكان وقامت
طائرات الاحتلال بقصف هذا المنزل دون سابق
انذار طبعا نشاهد حجم هذا
الدمار في هذا
البيت المنزل مكون من عده طوابق تم
تدميرها
بالكامل طبعا جل الشهداء من الاطفال ومن
النساء طبعا كما نشاهد هنا ما زالت
محاولات البحث مستمره عن عدد من
المفقودين يعني تقريبا على اذان العشاء
فاجانا سمعنا بخط بطين قويات جدا جدا جدا
جينا بسرعه مليون احنا وكل الجيران على
هذا الموقع لقينا بيت نسايبنا مضروب
الان كان عدد الشهداء مرميين السقوف واقع
عليهم اطفال مرميين على الطريق اصابات كان
في هذا البيت وتواجد اكثر من 50 شخص الان
كانت الدنيا يعني كنا ماشيين كنا على
كشافات التلفونات يعني طلعنا والان ننا
قاعدين ندور على بعض الناس المفقودين الان
في عننا 14 شهيد تقريبا من عائله 14
وفي حوالي عشرات الاصابات يعني بتحكي ب 30
اصابه موجوده كانت في هذا البيت
نعم انا ابن المستشار القاضي الشهيد علي
محمد هذا البيت بيت امن لا يحوي اي
كما يدعي الاحتلال اي افراد من افراد
المقاومه هذه اشلا طفل لابن اخي يبلغ من
العمر سنتين لا يرقب في الاطفال ولا
الشيوخ ولا النساء الله
يرحمهم ما زال الاحتلال يرتكب مجازر بحق
المواطنين الابرياء هنا في شمال غزه كان
اخرها منزل عائله في جباليا البلد
مما اسفر عن عدد من الشهداء والاصابات وما
زال تحت الركام عدد من المفقودين انس
الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه